- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna talk about kinetic energy
and we're also gonna think
about how to calculate it.
So you can already imagine
based on the word kinetic,
which is referring to motion
that this is the energy that an object has
by virtue of its motion.
And when we talk about energy,
we're talking about its
capacity to do work.
So just based on that early
definition of kinetic energy,
which of these two running backs
do you think has more kinetic energy,
this gentleman on the left
whose mass is a 100 kilograms
and who is traveling at a
speed of two meters per second,
or the gentleman on the right,
who has a mass of 25 kilograms
and who's traveling with a
speed of four meters per second?
Pause this video and think about that.
All right, now let's
think about this together.
So I'm first just gonna
give you the formula
for kinetic energy, but then
we are going to derive it.
So the formula for kinetic
energy is that it's equal
to 1/2 times the mass of the object,
times the magnitude of
its velocity squared,
or another way to think about it,
its speed squared.
And so given this formula, pause the video
and see if you can
calculate the kinetic energy
for each of these running backs.
All right, let's calculate
the kinetic energy
for this guy on the left.
It's gonna be 1/2 times his mass,
which is 100 kilograms, times
the square of the speed,
so times four meters
squared per second squared,
have to make sure that we
square the units as well.
And this is going to be
equal to 1/2 times 100
is 50 times four is 200 and
then the units are kilogram
meter squared per second squared.
And you might already recognize
that this is the same thing
as kilogram meter per
second squared times meters,
or these are really the units
of force times distance,
or this is the units of energy
which we can write as 200 joules.
Now let's do the same
thing for this running back
that has less mass.
Kinetic energy here is
gonna be 1/2 times the mass,
25 kilograms times the
square of the speed here,
so that's gonna be 16 meters
squared per second squared.
And then that gets us.
We're essentially gonna have
1/2 times 16 is eight times 25,
200, and we get the exact same units
and so we can go straight to 200 joules.
So it turns out that they have
the exact same kinetic energy.
Even though the gentleman
on the right has one fourth
the mass and only twice the speed,
we see that we square
the speed right over here
so that makes a huge difference.
And so their energy due to their motion,
they have the same capacity to do work.
Now, some of you are thinking,
where does this formula come from?
And one way to think about work and energy
is that you can use
work to transfer energy
to a system or to an object somehow.
And then that energy is
that object's capacity
to do work again.
So let's imagine some
object that has a mass m
and the magnitude of its
velocity or its speed is v.
So what would be the work necessary
to bring that object that has mass m
to a speed of v, assuming
it's starting at a standstill?
Well, let's think about it a little bit.
Work is equal to the magnitude of force
in a certain direction,
times the magnitude of the
displacement in that direction,
which we could write like that.
Sometimes they use s for the magnitude
of displacement as well.
And so what is the
force the same thing as?
We know that the force is the same thing
as mass times the acceleration.
And we're going to assume
that we have constant acceleration
just so that we can simplify
our derivation here.
And then what's the distance
that we're gonna travel.
Well, the distance is gonna
be the average magnitude
of the velocity, or we
could say the average speed,
so I'll write it like this,
times the time that it takes
to accelerate the object
to a velocity of v.
Well, how long does it take
to accelerate an object
to a velocity of v if
you're accelerating it at a?
Well, this is just gonna
be the velocity divided
by the acceleration.
Think about it.
If you're going, trying
to get to a velocity
of four meters per second,
and you're accelerating
at two meters per second, per second,
four divided by two is gonna
leave you with two seconds.
And if you're starting at a speed of zero
and you're going to a
magnitude of a velocity
or a speed of v, and you're
assuming constant acceleration,
your average velocity is
just gonna be v over two.
So this is just v over two.
And then we get a little bit
of a drum roll right over here.
We see that acceleration
cancels with acceleration,
and we are left with mass
times v squared over two,
mv squared over two,
which is exactly what
we had right over here.
So the work necessary
to accelerate an object
of mass m from zero speed to
a speed of v is exactly this.
And that's how much energy is then stored
in that object by virtue of its motion.
And if you don't have energy loss
it could in theory, do this much work.